I agree with the premise of the question
because the rate of change is just so
fast,
whether it's through globalization or
technology that you know,
if it were ever true that you could do
sort of a five year plan and then just
put it aside and executed.
It's certainly not true today.
Uh,
and there is a constant need to
innovate.
And one of the ways that we've benefited
is we do a lot of our business
development,
um,
in partnership structures,
uh,
whether that's in the US or globally.
And that allows us to kind of go to
school,
if you will,
on what other organizations are also
doing.
So for example,
take the mobile sector.
You know,
if you only looked at the u s market
where frankly our,
you know,
cell phones and our networks are so far
behind,
uh,
what it's possible to do with,
you know,
mobile devices in Europe or in Asia,
that you wouldn't even see the
possibilities.
But because we're a global company,
we were able to see six years ago the
potential for those devices being
entertainment devices as well as,
you know,
email and phone devices.
And began striking deals with companies
overseas to test different kinds of
content,
whether it was games or video.
So I think looking outside of your own
organization and working with your
partners,
even vendors can be an interesting
source of innovative ideas.